واجرى وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان اتصالا هاتفيا مع كل من رئيس
مجلس السياده السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان
وقائد القوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
حمادتي وقالت الخارجيه السعوديه ان الوزير
دعا خلال المحادثات للتهدئه وتغذيب
المصلحه الوطنيه ووقف كل اشعال اشكال
التصعيد العسكري وشدد وزير الخارجيه
السعودي على ضروره العوده الى الاتفاق
الايطالي الذي يضمن تحقيق الامن
والاستقرار
في الاثناء طالبت جامعه الدول العربيه
بضروره الوقف الفوري للاشتباكات المسلحه
في السودان حقنا للدماء وحذرت خلال اجتماع
عقد في القاهره على مستوى المندوبين
الدائمين من خطوره ما سمته التصعيد العنيف
في السودان وما يصاحبه انت داعيات خطيره
وشددت الجامعه العربيه على ضروره ان تعلن
الاطراف كافه مصلحه السودان عبر ممارسه
اقصى درجات ضبط النفس والعمل سويا على
تهدئه الاوضاع والعوده السريعه الى المسار
السلمي لحل الازمه السودانيه
وقال المتحدث باسم العمليه السياسيه في
السودان خالد عمر يوسف ان الحرب بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع يجب ان تتوقف فورا
ودون تاخير
واضاف المتحدث انه يامل ان تستجيب قياده
القوات المسلحه وقياده الدعم السريع
لنداءات وقف الحرب وانت تجنحاء للحل
السلمي المتفاوض عليهم واوضح ان الحرب
الحاليه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
ستمزق السودان وستفقده وحدته وسيادته